I’M JAMES DAVIS
AND I’M AMANDA SEALES
AND WE ABOUT TO DO IT REAL BIG,
KINGSMAN AND STATESMAN STYLE
[EXPLOSION]
GOT A BIT OF A SAVE THE
WORLD SITUATION HERE
WELCOME TO STATESMAN!
AS YOUR AMERICAN COUSINS
WE'LL BE WORKING SIDE BY SIDE
[GUNFIRE, EXPLOSION]
LET'S GET STARTED
WHO BETTER AT WHIPPING THAN JAMES?
I ACTUALLY WHOOPED MYSELF IN THE ASS
KEEP MESSING WITH THE BULL
YOU GONNA GET THE HORNS
[GUNFIRE]
YOU WANT SOME?
NICE TO BE WORKING WITH AN AGENT
WHO KNOWS WHAT HE’S DOING
DOES MY LAWYER KNOW ABOUT THIS?
[TIRES SCREECHING]
LET ME JUST SIT DOWN
CAN WE GET SOME WATER?
TIMES UP
SO, IVE DECIDED TO BE A KINGSMAN
SO YOU TELL COLIN AND TARON,
I’M ON THE WAY!
Y'ALL LOOK DAMN SHARP
YOU KNOW THAT, IT'S NEVER BIKINI WEATHER HERE
I CAN’T BE CHILLIN WITH Y’ALL NO MORE
HE’S NO LONGER BRITISH ADJACENT